BACK PRESSURE AS MUCH AS
PO A GREAT PLAY TOK DOOR AND I
FIND HIM.
>> HU CONTINUE TO
E THAT AND ST LOT OF WAYS OFFENI
MUCH AS POW C SHOTS.
TR ARE HAPPENING RIG
ZAJAC INTERCEPTS.
COLEMAN BACK TO ZAJAC.
PALMIERI WITH THE SHOT.
THAT GOES OFF RITTICH.
PLAYED ALL THE WAY AROUND FOR
LINDHOLM.
AND HE FIRES IT PAST TO MONAHAN.
GAUDREAU BREAKING THROUGH, RIGHT
IN, SCORES!
AND HE'S IN BEHIND THE
THIS SEASON, THE 30-YEAR-OLD.
SEAN MONAHAN, PUCK UP THE BOARDS
TO LINDHOLM.
BACK BEHIND THE NET FOR MONAHAN
FLAMES GOT BACK IN THIS CONTEST
WITH GOOD TIME DOWN LOW.
GET IN THERE AND START WINNING
PENALTY SHOT.
[ Cheers & Applause ]
>> Rick: JOHNNY GAUDREAU TO
PUT THE FLAMES IN THE LEAD.
[ Cheers & Applause ]
TWO GOALS IN THE FIRST 1:01 IN
SLOWLY BACK TO HIS FEET WAY
BEHIND THE PLAY.
PUCK PINBALLS AROUND.
HERE'S GAUDREAU, TWO-ON-ONE.
JOHNNY GAUDREAU PASSES, THEY
SCORE!
[ Sound of Horn ]
[ Cheers & Applause ]
IT'S DEREK RYAN, AND IT'S 6-4!
>> Rick: MOST GOALS MACKENZIE
BLACKWOOD.
>> Rick: LET HIM FIND A WAY TO
BATTLE THROUGH.
HE'S A 2--YEAR-OLD.
>> Rick: MONAHAN BACK ON THE
>> Rick: MOST GOALS MACKENZIE
BLACKWOOD.
>> Rick: LET HIM FIND A WAY TO
BATTLE THROUGH.
HE'S A 2--YEAR-OLD.
>> Rick: MONAHAN BACK ON THE
ICE, TO GAUDREAU, SCORES!
JOHNNY GAUDREAU BACK ON THE ICE
AS HE TAKES THE PASS OFF THE
BOARDS AND WORKS DOWN THE WING.
A LITTLE SPIN MOVE ON THE HALF
BOARDS.
TURNS BACK TO THE FOREHAND.
>> Harnarayan:
[ Cheers & Applause ]
MILESTONE GOAL FOR JOH
NN
YHOCKEY.
CALGARY WITH THE EARLY LEAD.
NW 3-1 FOR NEW JERSEY.
MARK GIORDANO WITH A NICE
NO-LOOK FEED FINDING AN OPEN SAM
BENNETT IN THE SLOT WHO SCORES
HIS.
DURING TV TIME-OUT WHEN YOUR
EQUIPMENT FAILS YOU.
THE GAME EXPLODING IN HIS FACE.